I can't wait for kurata virus the
musical coronavirus the musical can you
see it
Broadway stage opens 2023 people are
standing there it's kind of like rent if
you remember rent the stage is you know
there's no real set there's just some
garbage cans and some stuff and you know
there's a catwalk and kind of plain and
there's just like people standing on the
stage and you know 20 23 coronavirus the
musical you know the first number
everybody's standing there just like you
know they're doing it on the beat
doodle-ooh doodle-ooh uh-huh what was
that what was that I heard about a
pandemic happening
what was that Wu Han China what was that
pandemic bat flew plague playing in
about flu and then you know I mean it's
coming it's coming
where are the tests we thought we had
the tests just doctors and nurses
singing by the way isn't the worst thing
about this that we have to treat doctors
and nurses with reverence and respect
is there anybody more annoying than
doctors and nurses let's be honest I
mean I know that now they're essential
but I wish they weren't I wish we were
lying on like blackjack dealers or
people that I like doctors and nurses
they're almost as bad as teachers
imagine if we had to imagine if we all
had to glorify teachers during this oh
my god I would just go kill me now I do
like I do you know it's just doctors or
vet you know they're pompous doctors are
pompous and nurses as well think they're
doctors it's not all of them but it's a
fair amount of them and many people in
the medical field agree with me I'm just
saying I wish we were relying on another
group
that we had to exalt you know I don't
know who you know people that work at
clam bars a fat women who ladle clam
chowder in or a cop I wish they were the
front lines and we could be like yeah I
support I support Donna I mean you know
folks you have to remember when all this
is happening that you're living through
a historic time I love that isn't that
people tell you that like it's a good
thing you're living through a historic
time this is historic this is a historic
time it is a historic time you know so
was the Holocaust was historic you think
they walked around Auschwitz ago you
know what we have to remember we're
living in a historic time we really are
we just get to see it all up close you
think they talked about that probably
not but what do I know